Emily Barnard your book remember me to
Harlem is about what well the book is
about the Harlem Renaissance which was a
cultural movement that took place in
urban centers like New York and
Philadelphia and Boston Chicago during
1920s and that's what it is sort of in
the most general sense but it's also
really about a friendship between two
men who were as different as they could
be but forged a bond that saw them
through really their entire lives
where is Harlem Harlem is in Manhattan
it's Upper Manhattan and Harlem has had
a lot of different incarnations over the
course of its lifetime before it became
kind of the black Mecca as we call
during that period it we had it had
claimed members of Dutch residents
German residents Irish residents so it's
had a lot of different kinds of
manifestations what's it like today it's
it still has a lot of the same kind of
flavor as I did in the 20s I mean you
can still go to the street called
strivers row which was a home to
Harlem's elite you can still see the
magnificent architecture there and it
still claims a lot of sort of black
luminaries but of course it's seen a lot
of economic devastation since a sort of
booming economy that made it flourish
during the early part of the early 20s
if you buy your book what do you get if
you buy the book you get not only a
story I think an interesting story about
the Harlem Renaissance that incorporates
not only the stories about the black
figures who are so important to this
period but also a story about the
interrelationships between not only
black artists and writers until
intellectuals but white patrons as well
I think that's one of the stories about
the Harlem Renaissance it was difficult
to tell you also get I think an
interesting story in the footnotes of a
lot of important but now forgotten
figures who were incredibly exciting and
vibrant during their times who've really
just been written out of history so we
can get a kind of feel for the people go
through some of these photos first one
is a twofer who's in this photo right
there it's Langston Hughes and Carl Van
Vechten
taken by Richard Avedon in 1963
evident take a series of photographs of
Hughes and then victim that really
inspired me a lot while I was working on
the project I knew that he had become
interested in their friendship and their
relationship in the late 50s and
scheduled this photography session so it
was actually hard to pick one one of
them there are many of there that are
wonderful and funny and interesting that
he took during that photo session who's
this it's alfred knopf who started his
publishing house in 1915 and in 1916 I
think convinced when Beckman to publish
his first collection of essays with the
house and he and his house became
crucial to the development of like
literature during the 20s publishing
yearbook today absolutely yes yes and
this these are advertisements for [ __ ]
heaven and the first one on the Left
contains a caricature by miguel
Covarrubias who was a caricaturist and
an artist who then back and actually
helped to spearhead his career carving
beckon [ __ ] heaven has just been
published by Calvin Vechten the second
one is also an advertisement for the
book the illustration in that and the
second advertisement is done by Aaron
Douglas we'll come back to that look and
ask you more about it the next foot on
this list is the entrance to Van Vechten
s home yeah yeah where is the home 150
West 55th Street this was a the home
that was referred to by Walter white as
the Midtown branch of the n-double a-c-p
and that's a foray in the home for
somebody who's not been and in New York
the 55th Street is what relationship to
Harlem how far away is Harlem I mean
it's it's several blocks away and been
vecten actually you know that was what I
think was important about his placement
during his period because he literally
brought you know uptown downtown and
vice-versa
he really they were two different worlds
and he lived in you know at that point a
very elite white world and then he would
moved to Central Park West later in his
life and so he always lived in these
sort of elite mostly white neighborhoods
but he really you know physically
created a kind of integration by
bringing black people to his home and by
you know sort of shepherding White's to
Harlem Carl Van Vechten you say he was
married here's a photograph from 1923
who's the woman
vanya miranov she was a Russian actress
and they were married for 50 years very
interesting and kind of tumultuous
passionate relationship you say he was
also gay
um he was bender didn't certainly had
relationships with men and many
relationships with men the terms were
different then than they are now but he
was a man if he's considered gay now by
the language we use at this point at
that point there were different kinds of
terminology then with somebody who
openly and you know kind of actively
loved men where did he meet his wife on
you Mara no I believe he met his mother
wife in New York and she from originally
she was from Odessa originally in Russia
yes this next photograph include zora
neale hurston who we hear a lot about
who was she Zora Neale Hurston another
amazing figure from this period who was
born in Alabama and came to Harlem in
the 20s and was different than the kind
of the kind of elite group of the Harlem
Renaissance writers and that she was
less interested in kind of affecting
they sort of prim and proper heirs you
know she was a folklorist and she wrote
full plays and poetry and collected and
collected book materials and so she was
really impatient with a lot of the
prettiness that characterized a lot of
the other writing and kind of attitudes
about the Harlem Renaissance she had a
falling out at one point with Langston
Hughes over what right they had a
falling out 1931 over a play called meal
bone Hurston had collected a lot of
materials during her travels in the
south folklore mythology and it's a kind
of complicated story I think we've yet
to kind of understand what really
happened but some kind of romantic
jealousy was happening and they had a
very tense relationship with one called
godmother who hope we can talk about
later to Charlotte Mason who was her
patron and so it became a difficult
triangle actually I'm gonna ask where
there's other person involved as well
and they fell out but actually later
years were in contact again who was
Charlotte Mason Charlotte Mason was um
another kind of notorious patron of the
Harlem Renaissance and she I think
stands an important contrast I figure
like Robin Becton she was one of the
from one of the most wealthy elite
families in New York I'm she's a white
woman who considered you know the
Vanderbilt
sort of new money you know she was from
that kind of that kind of station and
life and she became interested her first
passion was Native American culture and
she became interested in things black in
the 1920s and developed relationships
with Alain Locke who was one of the kind
of gatekeepers of the Harlem Renaissance
and Elaine brought her two likes in
Hughes and Zora Neale Hurston and she
had her charges call her godmother you
know and they actually kneel before her
she sat on a throne you know and her
lavish apartment in New York and had
them kind of you know sort of kissed the
ring and really pay that kind of respect
to her so she was really someone who
enjoyed having a kind of almost
master-servant relationship with her
black protegees and she and Hughes had a
very wrenching relationship and they
fell out around the same time the meal
bone episode took place in the early 30s
and he was very emotionally dependent on
her really attached to her if you read
his letters to her which are also at
Yale's library you see how he really
needed a lot of he did some kind of
parental guidance he looked for in Mason
and she at some point just rebuffed him
entirely did she give him money she did
give him money how much do you have any
sense from reading you know I'm not I'm
not I'm not actually sure about um I
think these things are laid out some
detail in our Lorraine person's
biography of Langston Hughes of the life
of Langston Hughes
they had a contractual really actually
had a contract with him and I believe
that um Hurston received a little more
money than Hughes did but there the
country contract was I mean it's sort of
amazing in its detail you know he where
he could publish where he couldn't
publish with Hurston the UM she had to
come up with receipts for everything she
spent money on down to her stockings
down to her shoes um some heartbreaking
letters that both Hughes and her soon
would write to Mason asking for just
enough money you know just so I can get
a new pair of shoes she was relentless
you know in the control she exercised
over her black protegees we have a
photograph from your book of Blanche
Knopf 1932 who was she
Blanche Knopf married to Alfred Knopf um
she was really the one who worked with
Black Riders during the 20s she was the
one who worked most often with Langston
Hughes and it was often a triangle
between Langston and Van Vechten and
Hughes with Van Vechten really pulling
the strings he was the one who really
knew about black literature and brought
that knowledge to Blanche and said you
know here's a new here's a new avenue
for you to pursue and she would often
incorporate Van Vechten very words into
her letters with Hughes you know when
she disliked something he did or when
she went to encourage you know a
different kind of impulse in his writing
so she was the kind of middle person
between Van Vechten and Hughes for quite
a quite a bit of time as he Smith Bessie
Smith um
Empress of the blues Van Vechten was a
huge fan of Bessie Smith and took
several portraits of her and these are I
think two of the most well-known um he
liked to pose the you know African head
next figuration he would love these kind
of you know these kind of uh almost
these kind of literal distinctions you
know how did you get into this in the
first place well I was an undergraduate
at Yale and I had a class on
african-american literature with a
professor called Linda watts who was
really great and she gave students
suggested titles I should be sorry
suggested um topics for a paper and one
of them was to write about [ __ ] heaven
and its author
carmine Becton and I've never heard of
this person and I was you know appalled
to hear about this book called [ __ ]
heaven written by a white author in 1926
but I was equally intrigued and so I
just began to do research about it and
the more I learned about it the more I
just became really consumed by it
because I had only been interested in
Harlem Renaissance my parents are alums
of Fisk University my mother actually
you know studied with Robert Hayden and
you know was just part of the whole the
whole kind of collection of black genius
there at Fisk and really watched a lot
of things happen so I already knew about
the black artists who had become
well-known during that period but I had
never heard about this white person and
the more I read about about him I
learned about his relationship with
black writers and so I became interested
in the kind of interval
choose between whites and blacks during
this period and how difficult it was for
black people to kind of to kind of rest
with this this question you know what is
white influence and what what
relationship does it have to our art
does it take something away from the
integrity of black art or is it in fact
you know just sort of a necessary evil
is it possible for these kinds of
relationships to exist without certain
kind of power imbalances naturally
taking place and so that's the kind of
question that really I wanted to pursue
and then beckon it just really brings it
all to the front Fisk historically black
college located where Nashville
Tennessee and your parents what was
their relationship to Fisk well they
both had attended facin they both
actually live in Nashville now yeah what
did they do
my father is an ob/gyn and my mother is
his office manager and you found your
way to Yale at what year did you go to
Yale um I went to Yale um I started in
1985 I should also remember there was
also a poet as well and she studied with
Barbara Tatum um so I started in 85 and
I finished in 89 and then I went back
for graduate school in 90 but Yale has a
binary library it sounds like there are
some treasures in there oh absolutely
and that was you know a huge part of
what made what brought me to the project
I mean that I could walk just a few
paces and really had this whole world
open up and to see the you know the kind
of original letters and the original
effects of these these people was just
unbelievable and just incredible amount
of richness there has anybody ever done
anything like this the letters um
there's a great collection of letters
actually published between vine Becton
and Gertrude Stein two volumes of
letters they're really wonderful
wonderfully annotated there's also a
collection of letters between Langston
Hughes and Arne upon Tom's um who xarna
bond iron upon Tom's was a very close
friend of Hughes he was a librarian and
also an author he wrote children's books
a novel never gained the kind of
popularity of someone like Langston
Hughes but central kind of figure of
this period here's a photograph we'll
get on the screen of Langston Hughes and
Arnab on Thompson
Harold Jack Monroe Jack right who are
they
I mean not who are they but where was
this picture taken well the picture I
actually don't know where it was taken
um art Abad Tom's as I said was very
close to Hughes and Harold Jackman was
another sort of really central figure of
the period he was also a librarian I
think people I believe had some kind of
artistic ambitions I don't know if he
ever realized them but he was a very
close friend of Corbin veterans and they
correspond did he was active in the 40s
with Van Vechten Stage Door Canteen now
where did Carl Van Vechten and Langston
Hughes meet for the first time they met
in 1924 for the first time they met at a
benefit party at Arthur happy roons
nightclub on Lenox Avenue I think I had
in 43rd Street in Harlem and the first
time they met the invention was just
then sort of discovering you know this
kind of cultural flowering of called the
Harlem Renaissance you know that was
sort of just being initiated actually at
that time and so he was brought to the
party I think by Walter White who was
another gatekeeper of the period a
journalist someone was very politically
active who actually looked white and did
a lot of research on lynching using sort
of white skin to kind of help him
infiltrate you know various kinds of
goings-on in the south and so they
became they became friends first and
white introduced him to everyone and at
that that night in 1924 he met Langston
Hughes and the first night he recorded
his name as Kingston Hughes and it
wasn't until several months later in 25
and they met again was another benefit
party that they really developed their
relative real friendship in the 20s what
was it like for black people in the
United States well in the 20s was also
the horizon's' coincides with the period
known as the great migration and in the
late teens and early 20s
scores of black people are coming from
the south you know sort of ravaged
political repressive situations coming
to urban centers like New York Chicago
Philadelphia looking for work and
there's a kind of push-pull a situation
with them as I said black people really
really needing to find alternatives
beyond this
and urban industries needing labor and
so that's a kind of situation that
creates the bulk of black people in in
cities like Harlem then gives away to
something like the Harlem Renaissance
but the situation in the north was of
course not
not the promised land not not the kind
of a situation of equality and liberty
but often black people came to the north
and found that jobs that were promised
them were were not not to be had they
found an equal amount of repression
politically also violence so the
situation was not you know what it would
it had been promised to be but it still
was a time when black people like every
other American was was benefiting from
post post war economy and so there's a
lot of you know kind of conspicuous
consumption and a lot of good of good
hope some sense of possibility for black
people as well where was Langston Hughes
born was born in Joplin Missouri and why
due to parents what were they like well
his mother was Carrie Clark who was
someone who had a lot of ambitions she
wanted to be an actress and she of
course she would have you know roles and
various performances I think it's in the
letters actually comes up she has a ends
up having an important role in a Harlem
production and she she really wanted you
know sort of a lot for her son but
wasn't able to really provide him with
any kind of real stability because she
divorced her husband I think in the
teens and so he was ended up having kind
of a links instead of having kind of a
nomadic upbringing with Carrie trying to
find work in various you know situations
and living with with family members
things like that
James Nathaniel Hughes was Hughes's
father who was a very difficult man
Hughes writes about him in his 1940
autobiography as being someone who just
really didn't want to identify with
black Americans at all and had a real
disdain for for African Americans and
this caused Hughes a lot of inner
turmoil that he writes about in the big
see they was it was episode if it wasn't
an easy upbringing from big sees the
autobiography line item Hughes yes what
was the difference in age between why
Hughes and Carl Van Vechten and wordid
van Becton come from the vegetables that
was about 20 years older about 22 years
older than Langston Hughes he was born
in Cedar Rapids Iowa to very sort of
prominent parents were prominent members
of the community
his father was an insurance broker and
quite well-to-do he was also someone
who's sympathetic to black rights and
used some of his money to help found a
school for free black children at the
turn of the century
his mother was a suffragist who was
interested in you know women's rights to
vote and so it's that kind of situation
that really led to a lot of early
curiosity and the part of car from
beckoned a lot of his interest in
looking outside of the mainstream for
different evidence of culture and [ __ ]
heaven the book where did the title come
from when did Van Vechten write it and
what impact did it have on his life well
the title comes from it was a kind of
ironic term that was used actually among
black people
around the time of time period of
segregation it refers to the segregated
situation and Public Theater's like in
the balcony buckle were forced to sit in
the balconies sitting you know sort of
at a kind of interesting vantage point
over the heads of white people but yet
forced to sit in segregated segregated
and quote-unquote inferior seating
seating so it's admit to be sort of
ended minutes be kind of an ironic
comment on the situation of blacks in
America on segregation and the kind of
cruel teasin absurdities of segregation
and racism he also really understood the
title might have some commercial
advantages he had been the one to
convince Ronald for bank to use a title
prancing [ __ ] for I believe a novel
he'd vote and I can I forget I forget
the date I think was 1924 and for venko
had originally talked titled his book
sorrow and sunlight but been Becton it
was a phrase in the book thought you
know this book actually has some
commercial potential and this title has
commercial potential
so the emerging new
you know it would might really have some
nice for reverberations to have a title
that was volatile that was provocative
although he claimed of course until the
end of his life that the title was meant
to be ironic and was just a shame that
you know people were so unsophisticated
they couldn't appreciate the you know
the layered meanings of the title he
published it in 1926 he published it
months after he had written a couple of
essays one of them was not really an
essay he had authored a symposium titled
Hal Sheldon Negro be portrayed an art
that he published in the crisis magazine
which was the cultural organ of the
n-double a-c-p was a magazine for the
organization and the symposium sort of
canvassed writers all over the United
States and asked questions about the
representation of black people in art
what kinds of what kinds of images of
blacks were damaging to the social
progress of african-americans or should
art just exist on its own did it have to
take political accountability and the
the responses were kind of really varied
but Van Vechten zone response he said
something like you know it's really
important for the black artists to
understand that this is a moment you
know when things black or popular and
you should take advantage of it you
should exploit white interest you know
for your own benefit and and really the
commercial issues are the ones that are
most salient and he also published
another essay called moanin with a sword
in my hand which is uses the same kind
of argument you know now is not the time
to be sensitive about things like racial
racial epithets or characterizations of
black people I mean people want this
exotic material why don't you just use
it why don't you just exploit it so it's
on the heels of those kinds of
sentiments that he publishes [ __ ]
having which you can imagine black
response those intellectuals who had
read his writings on the subject were
furious you know they thought it was a
real slap in the face that he had
actually been kind of going behind
people's backs and collecting material
about about friends you know and then
using it to kind of better his own kind
of situation or popularizes
his own purse reputation what was
Langston Hughes reaction to [ __ ]
heaven
well Langston Hughes I think was one of
many of his vendetta's black friends who
tried to convince him to maybe think
about another title Gainesville and
Johnson also was really trying to urge
him to think about a different title who
was James Weldon Johnson Dave Tolin
Johnson was a central um kind of figure
during the Harlem Renaissance and beyond
he was an educator a lyricist
the author of the co-author with his
brother Osmond of lift every voice and
sing which is now called the Negro
national anthem the black national
anthem he wrote the book I've collected
the book of American Negro spirituals in
1922 which was a really signal kind of
collection of you know sort of putting
together black spirituals and Gospels
and work songs and talking about this is
like this is our contribution you know
really to American culture he was also a
the author of the autobiography of an
ex-colored man which was the first
modern novel authored by an African
American it was first published as an
autobiography 1912 and then reissued
actually at the behest of Corbin Becton
as a novel in 1927
let's connect some of the dots you
mentioned Fisk University and Yale where
you went in the James Weldon Johnson
collection right at the Bonnie key
library at Yale and Van Vechten who was
responsible for a lot of what was the
relation between Ben vecten and Fisk
that mission was friends with the
president of Fisk at the time Charles
Johnson who was another kind of you know
kind of luminary of this period and
leader you know of sort of black
politics at this time and then Thurston
was also familiar with Fisk's history
you know as a real home for black
intellectuals I was called the Harvard
of the sort of black Harvard you know
because it was a place where you would
go for that kind of you know if you're
really intellectually ambitious as a
black person you know during the ER of
segregation so he was familiar with the
reputation of the university and I've
had friends you know very spends on the
faculty orna on Tom's head started his
job as a librarian there so he
came familiar with the kind of the
seriousness of the institution from the
inside out and so it was because and it
was because of his relationship with I
think various individuals there that he
decided to establish that collection
there I mean he had an interest in
putting black collections of white
institutions and vice-versa he really
felt that that would be something that
would contribute to the end of ignorance
why did he think black people want to
know about George Gershwin well I think
he felt more than anything that George
Gershwin kind of belonged FS because of
his his facility with black music you
know and his appreciation of a black
culture through the music and I think he
also believed that it would be important
for white scholars to come down to Fisk
University and and do the work there at
on this black campus as it worked I
think it really has worked I mean I it
worked for me it worked for me al I
think if it hadn't been for the James
Weldon Johnson collection I really would
never have made my way you know to the
dusty old rooms at the binary library to
do that work there now who or which
these folks are in the James Weldon
Johnson collection at Yale who's in
there
who's in there well actually all of them
in there really um it really is an
amazing collection um I would say with
the exception of a Zorro Herson her
papers are kind of scattered now they've
been there her letters are coming
together and a great volume edited by
Carla Kaplan but her son's letters are
kind of scattered all over all over the
country so with the exception of Hurston
who's some of her papers are in DC at
Howard there's also a great collection
there most everyone else really the
price of primary kind of um receptacle
you know name some um I've and exes
papers are there connections of papers
are there is why right exactly um he
also has a collection at the New York
Public Library
um James Weldon Johnson Spade err no
Larson Countee Cullen Alain Locke
actually a lot of his papers are here at
Howard see how many letters does
Langston Hughes have on file Oh
thousands thousands of letters and file
written longhand a lot of them written
longhand he really I think preferred
that to write longhand and how long did
you personally spend in there going
through these
well over the course of you know four
years
I I spent you know sort of months at a
time as long as I could you know kind of
with the letters when I first became
aware of them I was still I was both the
first time to graduate and then a
graduate student so I had more and I was
there at Yale so I had time to kind of
go on a daily basis and see what was
available but as time went by I was sort
of whenever I could make the trips so
all these are letters between Van
Vechten and Hughes like how many total
letters in your book I'm in my book
about 350 letters I'm just going to read
I just open the page that's 77 with a
hundred and fifty six yellow warblers
bearing pink and blue candy hearts in
their beaks Carlo what am i reading
that's one of Carla's many fanciful sign
ups that he would send to he was into
actually many of his correspondence with
seventeen royal purple dachshunds
housebroken
with polished silver legs right exactly
there are little little poems all of
them in a really loved language and he
loved to create pictures with with
language but you said in the book you
read that he got upset with mice and
here's because he kept signing his
letters sincerely right he said once
since they were the butcher he really
that really bothered him when he would
write him these flats my house but he
just didn't have the same kind of
interest and that kind of banter but he
did it he would do it and I think he was
actually when Hughes writes those and he
writes more elaborate sign offs they
often point more to social conditions or
that are going on at the time Evan Burt
one point II would you know cool dreams
to you in this buttnik world and this
wasn't you know sort of the early 50s so
he's he's really interested making a
different of commentary them in victim
who's who's plaintiffs tend to be really
kind of insular and and self reverential
the the poem about the Waldorf Astoria
yeah in the back
but with the circumstances around it and
why did you put it in the appendix I put
in the appendix because it had caused
such a stir and in not only he's his
personal life but also had kind of
professional reverberations I think
throughout the course of his his um
his career I mean it really it was the
beginning of huge his interest in his
professional kind of career to
incorporate some more political
sentiments it wasn't the first political
forming row by any means but I think it
was it's one that had many
reverberations for him he calls it the
pond that ends his relationship with his
patron but it actually wasn't he
actually would the poem after they'd
already broken off I think his patron
Charlotte miss him but in his in his
autobiography he uses it as a kind of
signal poem that really created a lot of
love chaos in his life it's a pawn that
you know when beckoned a lot of problems
with and I think it's representative of
inventions you know just this taste
where he says political poetry so the
their correspondence about this poem I
think you know give you a sense of what
Ben Benton's how they differed they
really couldn't have been more different
politically let me read a little bit of
it and then get you to interpret some of
it it says at the top advertisement for
the Waldorf Astoria what's that mean
well Idol the title I think he was
actually using what he was doing and he
wrote about this later and maybe it's in
the letters that I've used here he took
an actual ad for the Waldorf and really
did his own - the inspiration for the
poem was an actual ad for the Waldorf so
that's what the reference is - an ad it
would been popular during the time
period yeah right after that says fine
living a la carte question mark come to
the Waldorf Astoria and then it says
listen hungry ones look see what Vanity
Fair says about the new Waldorf Astoria
all the luxury of private home now
won't that be charming when the last
flophouse has turned you down this
winter furthermore it is far beyond
anything hitherto attempted in the hotel
world this is part of the ad it costs 28
million dollars the famous Oscar Shirky
is in charge of banqueting Alexander
gusto is chef it will be a distinguished
background for society so when you've
got no place to go homeless and hungry
ones homeless and hungry ones choose the
Waldorf as a background for your rags or
do they still consider the subway after
midnight good
enough what's he getting at here well
then um here's was really he was about
this actually beautifully and eloquently
and the big see he wrote about how at
this point in his life he's really at a
crossroads he's being supported by his
patron who lives in another world alter
her own and yet he's in as he goes to
the Park Avenue home and he sees outside
of the window the you know people
huddled in the corners just you know
it's the depression you know and there's
they're just numbers of people on the
streets who are absolutely destitute and
the contradiction is something he just
can no longer bear and it's no longer
possible for him kind of poetically to
leave those observations out of his work
and in terms of the contradictions at
the Waldorf kind of presents I think in
the poem you know how is it possible to
have this kind of opulence
you know when so many people in the
country have lost have lost everything
like he says here have lunch in there
this afternoon all you jobless why not
dining with some of the men and women
who got rich off of your labor who
clipped coupons with clean white fingers
because your hands dug cold drilled
stone sewed garments poured steel to let
others draw dividends and live easy did
this have any impact at the time I was
published it did have some impact I mean
there was there were letters of course
in support of the poem he was certainly
not alone you know in his is kind of
searing indictment you know of some of
the waldorf-astoria but in terms of his
you see in the correspondence Bendectin
was really bothered by the poem he what
he takes goes to great lengths I think
even years later to say to hew as you
know you know the Waldorf has has these
kinds of good qualities and it gives us
kinds of jobs to people and it's
actually one of the greatest employers
here in New York so he's very defensive
and it certainly becomes a little burr
in the relationship between van vecten
in here's so you have carbon vaccine
lives in midtown Manhattan right and
Langston Hughes who lives way up in a
hundred and thirty fifth or 26 or 27 st.
Nicholas Avenue far away he's black and
that consuella
he wants to shift all these documents to
the John the James Weldon Johnson
project at Yale when did that start back
there
well Janesville Johnson died tragically
in a car accident 1938 and after that I
think the Library of Congress approached
his widow grace nail to contribute her
papers to the Library of Congress her
husband's papers and that gave been
beckoned the idea because he had course
was close to grace nail I see had been
close to James Weldon Johnson to think
about creating an archive you know a
place where you could really have you
know could really build on you know this
collection and create you know perhaps
maybe even create a a chair of
african-american literature actually
talks about that in the letters years
before des actually would ever happen at
Yale he says he predicts that it might
happen you have a photo in there from
1950 opening of the James Weldon Johnson
memorial collection of American Negro
Arts and Letters at Yale University
what's that photo who do you recognize
anybody in there absolutely
well van vecten is taking the photograph
um taking a photograph it's actually the
person who's taking the photograph of
Van Vechten taking the photograph is
Saul maribor I believe who was a close
friend of Ben beckons and like a light
lighting assistant toward the end of his
life and it's at one point a lover of n
beckons he's looking almost directly at
Donald Gallup who's since passed away
who was a friend and someone who was a
partner in crime and his kind of
establishment of the Yale collection
really they worked together kind of
conspiring to put this together and
that's linked in Hughes with his hand to
the side of his to the side of his face
one of the few photographs were they're
actually in the same room or in the same
area in your letters that you've got
here you see Van Vechten nudging Hughes
all the time where is this stuff where's
this stuff
where's this stuff how long did that go
on years it went over here said it was
really aggravating you know um but
Vantage was determined to get Hughes to
you know sort of collect putting his
materials send them to Yale collect them
together and on one hand I mean it's
really aggravating even for the person
they're putting this collection together
to read letter after letter or this kind
of nudging hedging hedging but on the
other hand you know if an Becton hadn't
done that we wouldn't have this
collection well I keep thinking when I
was reading it the letters that you were
the great
factor here and they kept saying if you
don't get these letters in the future
generation won't be able to study this
and there you were reading this yeah
yeah absolutely yeah yeah there's an
interesting kind of self-consciousness I
think that happens you know between the
two of them because um you know the
later letters after vendek and has come
up with this idea to create the James
Bolden Johnson collection and he's
really beseeching Hughes you know please
send your letters to me he writes you
you know you have to write me back
because our letters were historic you
know our letters are really going to
mean something as you say for future
generations and it there's a funny
letter when he's you know it's saying
well if you hadn't told me that I would
tell you this really scandalous story
had happened but any proceeds to tell it
but too bad I've seen my letter C Yale
because I have to be you know much more
circumspect about about this kind of
material now you have a one page in here
is full of photographs of Langston
Hughes when I show this tell us about
this man how big was he was he married
what was his relationship with men or
women um like the news was not very big
he was um I don't I don't even believe
he was six feet tall um I suppose
in contrast another contrast yet to Van
Vechten he was quite tall and gangly and
and imposing as a figure like say he's
was not not none of those things he was
very handsome and it's kind of as as a
beautiful spirit as he was you know sort
of a person tool to admire he was never
married there's a lot of speculation
about he's a sexuality and has caused
quite a bit of you know controversy
among those of us interested in through
the Harlem Renaissance there's no sort
of definite information about his
sexuality but he's largely believed to
have been a gay man or someone who at
some point um you know enjoyed men in a
romantic way but we don't have any real
evidence about it but that's a sort of
that's how he sort of been being read
now you do have evidence according to
your footnotes all through the book that
he had relationships with women well
right he did talk a talk he talks in his
autobiography about several different
women and those come up in the letters
as well he tells men Becton about them
and then you even had a note which is
rather personal about his gonorrhea that
he got when he was like Carmel where did
you find out he
well a lot of this material I'm was so
grateful to have the brand besides
biographies he did extensive work for
years you know finding out about Hughes
so that materials there he also talked
about it in some of his other letters
too to some of his other close friends
but you know once again we have no idea
how he contracted the gonorrhea we can
only speculate what was he doing in
Carmel for that year anyway well a he
had a close friend and patron called
Noel Sullivan who was a patron of the
Arts from an old San Francisco family
someone who was beloved by many and was
very interested in black arts and they
met I believe I forget how they met
perhaps at a huge reading or they were
introduced actually buy a mutual mutual
friends and know all they correspond did
while he was was traveling and at some
point know invited Hughes to come to
live in his cottage and a cottage he had
his own have his own quarters and and
live and write and write he was working
a book of short stories at that point a
little seaside village of about 5,000
people but I didn't see any reference to
the him being black and living there
that was that a problem out there well
actually it did become it didn't quite
become a problem it's hard to say which
was more of a problem the race issue the
fact that Hughes was connected at that
point with a lot of leftist who had you
know sort of there's an old kind of
leftist tradition among the the
residents there and at some point there
were some notices in local papers about
you know about this black poet who was
living there but it seemed to sort of
have have as much to do with a fear of
you know communism and the kind of
leftist beliefs that Hughes was really
exploring upton sinclair live there and
there was the john reed clubs right now
what what's the politics of all that
well he was very active in the john reed
clubs and he really you know flirted
pretty seriously with communism at
different points in his life and i think
there's a letter in there actually
writes to to Van Vechten because when
victim was not someone who's interested
in liberal politics or politics at all
and he sort of at some point hints that
this has become part of his activity out
in Carmel but yeah this was something
that he was always a huge part of his
life the question of whether or not to
affiliate formerly with communism or
whether or not just to affiliate sort of
intellectually with it John Reid buried
in the Kremlin wall on American
Communist but what you talk about
Langston Hughes spending a lot of time
in Russia was he economist
um he was it never formally affiliated
himself with communism and it's
something that came a tender issue when
he was called before he whack to testify
house on American Activities Committee
right when was he AK 1957 I forget the
day but he was called to testify and his
testimony is very careful a very very
painstakingly avoids having avoids
affiliating himself with communism but
also every treaty repudiating it as well
so it's difficult to say I mean you know
there's a lot of rewriting that's been
done
he certainly believed and and and
enjoyed affiliations with other with
with with communist in the United States
and when he was in Russia really
explored you know those those kinds of
his impulses but he avoided sort of
having formal and I became as time went
on and he really started to suffer
politically and professionally from his
affiliations he distanced himself more
and more how long did he spend in Russia
um I believe he spent several months in
Russia he traveled the whole time there
was a whole group of I think the number
was 21 right like folks had went over to
Russia and and what was he there's a
letter in here where they talked about
how they were he felt he was being
treated better over there right it was a
group that was gonna go over and do a
film I believe it's called black and
white the film and the some never got
off the ground but he had a lot of
experiences and rights defend acting
about them and it's I think it's those
letters are wonderful contrasts of
inventions very kind of in some way
sedentary and kind of parochial life in
New York and why he's just traveling and
trying to understand himself and have
global context and then victim kind of
living
his parlor you know in New York when did
you know you had a book here I think I
knew I had a book early on you know when
I first saw these letters I ban to tell
people you know this is a wonderful
story you know I'm waiting for that the
time would there'd be a kind of real
writer
a real scholar to do it and then at some
point decided that it was my project at
a friend actually who told me you have
to do this book how did you get cut off
to buy your book well I was lucky enough
to be working for a woman called faith
child who's now my agent he was an agent
in New York and you know between times
when you know sort of doing working with
her began discussing with her this
project and we both thought it was
important to to try to do and we thought
you know we try trike enough at first I
was very lucky even on another level
because my editor at Knopf is Judith
Jones and she had been huge his editor
actually when he was you know an older
man and she was a young woman who just
come into publishing so she had so she
had the kind of a really interesting
perspective on him and a wonderful be
able to work with someone who actually
had worked with worked with him other
connections in your book the Ford
Foundation fellowship was that to write
the book no I got a poor Foundation
fellowship when I was a graduate student
what do you do for them um I was just
they actually provide fellowships for
minority students who were sort of
beginning their graduate work enables
you to travel in the summer and and not
have to worry about you know so working
alongside you know doing your class
works well you get a masters degree a
PhD PhD from Yale in what American
Studies not african-american
right uh national education I mean an
excellent down for the Humanities
fellowship right was that for the book
that was for the book yes how does that
work well I applied for the fellowship
hoping to have I knew I needed to have
some time to just concentrate on the
book and so I applied for it and was you
know so happy to finally get that letter
and realized to have a year off on at
the time I was teaching at Smith and so
they had the opportunity to spend the
year the Dubois Institute actually at
Harvard where I worked on the book every
day it was a glorious experience
what is the de voice Institute at
Harvard the deputy BD voice Institute
for afro-american research is a great
opportunity and it's a kind of um it's a
it's an institute founded on among other
by among others him you Lewis gates he
sort of spearheads the Institute and it
enables fellows from all over the world
really to come together have office
space and we had weekly colloquia we met
and discussed our projects it was
fantastic and are there any strings
attached when you get a National
Endowment for the Humanities grant what
you have to do for them well you have to
you hopefully produce something at the
end of it but at the at the very least
you produce you give them a sense of
what you have you spent your time they
want kind of a report at the very least
and you know hopefully some some
evidence that that you've actually been
doing what you're supposed to be doing
you have another poem in the index
called goodbye Christ and it starts off
listen Christ you did all right in your
day I reckon but that day is gone now
they go stood you up a swell story to
called it Bible but it's dead now the
Pope's and the preachers have made too
much money from it they've sold you two
too many
I can go on here but what's the point of
this well this is who's really you know
getting disgusted with a lot of what he
saw evidence of organized religion
religion in the United States
I think somebody who points out in the
poem or he kind of been really indict
says Aimee Semple McPherson she's
mentioned they said go ahead on now
you're getting in the way of things Lord
and please takes st. Gandhi with you
when you go and st. Pius and st. Aimee
McPherson right she she was um I think
one of the best-known American
evangelists who you know her own
biography is really pretty phenomenal
but this poem really is you can imagine
really upset her and she subsequently
staged a lot of demonstrations actually
when he was was giving readings and
talks at various you know locations she
would be outside picketing with her with
a group of protesters so it
huge hues an enormous amount of distress
and he writes about it in his letters
for Van Vechten
I think it's a time when he's in the
hospital with gonorrhea he writes defend
vexing about he actually he says that
it's not McPherson but he has been he
ends up retracting the poem and saying
you know kind of I didn't mean it you
know it was a mistake
how big a deal was he when he was alive
he was a very big he was really very
important I mean he was one of those
rare writers who really reached out and
was understood and appreciated by you
know an enormous kind of spectrum of
readers he could go to anyways about the
sins or even his early years he could go
to college campus campuses all over the
country and people would recite his
poetry to him I mean he's a hero among
black people people who didn't have
means to sort of you know collect maybe
a range of books and you were familiar
with Langston Hughes you know he was a
folk poet he was a poet of the people as
he called himself and he really was he
was someone who was you know spoke to
people where they were
and not just to the elite but spoke to
the everyday person and made it that his
business to do that so he was unique in
that respect um and he was blood he was
beloved all over the world there's a one
footnote in here about Nora
Thurston when she threw a fitter temper
tantrum yeah yeah what was she like um
she was another kind of formidable
an interesting complex character and
it's gonna be interesting when the
letters Carla Kaplan letters come out I
think that will paint a picture she was
um I kind of clastic daring bold um what
was she done throwing a fit and rolling
around the floor
well she at that point they were having
the dispute over her mule bone and so
what was Mille bone meal that was a folk
play based on one of the tales that her
son had collected when she was traveling
around the south looking for material
and it was a it was a comedy and it's
actually has been produced since since
this time I think in the 80s by George
Houston bass who was Hughes's um
secretary at some point and later the
executor of his estate until he died
relatively recently but person was you
know very dramatic soul and so when she
came to been Victor's house and through
this temper tantrum when imagine she did
it mostly for effect than anything else
you were trying to complete all the
picture you got Fisk University Yale
University and you then found your way
to Smith in Northampton Massachusetts
what did you do there I taught in the
afro-american studies department and I
taught um I taught a survey of
african-american literature and also a
class in the Harlem Renaissance and
another class on gender in the African
American literary tradition a class on
race and ethnicity and American
literature happened there for two years
when did you leave well I I was unli um
and what would have been my third year
at the Dubois Institute and then I got
engaged and moved in with my fiancee and
where do you live now
I live in Harrisburg Pennsylvania was
Ruth Simmons the president of smithing
you're there yes what was it like being
an african-american with a president of
a school in the Northeast like that
who's now going to brown um it was a I
could have asked for a better situation
um where Simmons is someone who um is as
strong leader as she is a person with
enormous integrity I mean I say that
quite seriously she's really um she was
irreplaceable and it's really too bad
for Smith but she's a force I mean she's
just she's bigger than bigger than just
a president really um of a book of a
college so I'm not surprised that she
was sort of called to move on but she
was that she was really someone who um
who who could leave not only students
but you know trustees she had everyone
kind of um everyone understood the
mission that she was really spearheading
they've acted it the the Moscow
connection cuz he writes this and you
have in the book there it seemed to me
that Marxism had put into practical
being many of the precepts which our own
Christian America and not yet been able
to bring to life for in the Soviet Union
meager as the resources of the country
were white and black Asiatic and
European Jew and Gentile
alike as citizens on an equal footing
protected from racial inequality by law
what do you think he would think if he
came back today
I think he'd write the same thing that's
interesting I'm not sure what he would
say I know that when he left and when we
actually his experience in Japan we're
really really contrasted that and we're
really devastating went to Japan he was
under suspicion the whole time when he
was there and he wrote also about about
that experience and what it was like to
be in a color I'm sorry in a country run
by people of color and be just as
isolated just as alienated just as
dehumanized as he was in the United
States so in some ways you know he'd a
lot of contradictory experiences in some
ways his dreams were were realized at
some moments you know with his
experience in the Soviet Union but other
times he was faced with reality of kind
of racism worldwide we have more photos
from this book and how many photos did
you put in the book and who took most of
them oh I think they're in excess of 60
photographs in the book and then dozen
took quite a bit of the photographs took
a good percentage of them and you say
that he had something like 15,000
negatives that back here in the back
somewhere reading in one of these are
you taken right what what happened to
all of us is net where are all of his
negatives today well they're archived a
lot of them are at the James Bond
Johnson collection at Yale some of them
are in the New York Public Library this
is Ethel Waters Van Vechten
was a huge fan of waters and really a
champion of her career I thought she was
you know one of the most important kind
of Negro performers and personalities
alongside Langston Hughes and so the
letters he talks about that so he really
championed Ethel Waters this is a Ethel
toi Harper who was Lincoln's kind of
surrogate mother he called her aunt toi
and lived with it with her and her
husband Emerson in Harlem and the later
part of his life why um why would he
live with them well he they were like
family to him
I think I'm Hughes enjoyed a solitude
but he also sought out these kind of
familiar situations like with Noel
Sullivan he had a whole community out
there in Carmel and then he had
something the equivalent in Harlem with
the Harper's so he liked to have that
balance
live alone but also in a house that was
really a home Carl Van Vechten was how
much older then mics in here so 22 years
older than Hughes and here he is again
with at the Stage Door Canteen what was
that surgery Kenton was the
entertainment kind of a outfit for
enlisted personnel during World War two
and I believe been Dutch was either on
the board of directors or fania
Maranatha Ashley was a person I think
who got him involved in the surgery or
campaign but it was a kind of
entertainment wing for enlisted men and
it was a very interesting then that can
talked a lot about in the letters and
what he enjoyed about so much was how
much whites and blacks interacted as
equals in that space and he was devoted
he was a actors and writers and singers
would would were would bus tables and
sweep the floors for the for the
personnel Billie Holiday
well Holliday inimitable Billie Holiday
Bendix was also a huge fan of hers and
writes about a photography session with
her in the letters and this is these are
photograph from the session Sidney
pottier
while this Mary McLeod Bethune educator
and visionary of the early 20th century
big statue to her in Lincoln Park right
here not about 14 blocks from where we
were sitting in the end did you find a
next book out of this um yes I think the
next book will sort of pick up on this
issue and I want to do an anthology of
essays personal essays written by
present-day
thinkers writers performers about
interracial friendships because one of
the most exciting things to me about the
story is how dedicated and passionate
these two men were about cultivating a
relationship at a time when it was
almost legally prohibited for black
people to to interact as peers as equals
what do you think of the interracial
relationships today in this society I
think you see progress in some respects
and also a lot of sad anachronistic
unfortunate kind of kinds of
interactions of students today
to me all the time in the kind of the
kind with a kind of malaise about oh
it's just too bad that you know people
why people are sort of permanently
racist you know and I tell them this is
not where we should be right now but
there was kind of acceptance I think at
cynicism often even young people today
have about interracial interactions and
this is something that was Sainz in
dramatic contrast to the kind of passion
and you know an excitement a possibility
that interracial connections had for
thinkers of the Harlem Renaissance any
other names out of the Harlem
Renaissance we talked about
oh so many Leroy Jones was he Harlan
assad's James ball most Harmonized kind
of a Black Arts Movement and that
generation really found a lot to
criticize about the Harlem Renaissance
they felt it was actually the potency of
the movement they felt was diluted by
white influence and white money and
sober Laura Jones and James Baldwin
really try to create a movement that can
exists the Black Arts Movement existed
in reaction to the Harlem Renaissance
once you exist without white support
remember me to Harlem is the name of
this book letters between Langston
Hughes and Carl Van Vechten our guest
has been the editor Emily Bernard thank
you very much thank you